rhede und zwar schnell
du ziehst der film über den wir reden
ist terminator bargfeld das ist der
sechste teil der terminator franchise
spielfilm franchise die auch noch comics
und babbel kommen und so was alles
enthält aber als sechster teil schließt
direkt an den zweiten teil von 1991
terminator 2 judgment day an
mein name ist sarah connor der 29 august
1997 sollte der tag der abrechnung sein
aber ich habe die zukunft geändert ich
rettete 3 milliarden leben reicht dir
das zusammenfassung
nein es kommen zwei leute zurück die in
den beiden original filmen die james
cameron damals inszeniert hat die
hauptrollen gespielt haben nämlich
arnold schwarzenegger als toaster
radiowecker und killermaschine und denn
da hamilton als seien vorgesehen das
opfer dass das aber nicht werden will
und dann auch nicht wild ich komme
wieder
wir sind beide bisschen älter geworden
und was sie damals waren nämlich jäger
und gejagte ist ersetzt durch zwei neue
schauspieler von relativer
beschaffenheit und zwar ist das eine
natalia es die spielt eine frau namens
daniel die diesmal gejagt wird und dass
anderes gabriel una den wird unter
anderem als ghostwriter aus marseille in
southfield kennen der diesmal den
radiowecker spielt derselben möchte
[Musik]
seither ist viel passiert und das stürzt
alles ineinander und aufeinander und
über alle berge
warum sagst du dich und sie weil ich sie
war das schöne daran ist dass wenn man
die beiden originale nicht gesehen hat
und also in einer art kulturellem sinkt
noch gelebt hat
dass man dann sozusagen durch die pure
präsenz und die art wie die sich
zueinander verhalten von den hamilton
und arnold schwarzenegger eigentlich
genug mitgeteilt kriegt darüber wie
schwierig ihre sagen wir doch einfach
beziehungen zueinander ist
ich sehe du bist sehr aufgebracht ich
helfe dir das mädchen zu beschützen
stoffel und maschine allerdings extrem
humorvoll also es gibt ja fast nichts
lustiges als arnold schwarzenegger
männer so guckt hat er gelernt von clint
eastwood bei dem es noch lustiger ist
eigentlich und das anderes in der
hamilton die sich halt gegen diese
stoffe leyen gegen dieses maschinenwesen
natürlich immer noch behaupten kann und
unter anderem schöne alte feministische
grundsätze auspackt wie und wenn du mir
selbst alles klaus lasse mir meine
panzer kaum
das heißt die beziehung dieser beiden
ist relativ klar und interessant ist
dann nur dass die erwartungen die
dadurch aufgebaut werden entweder indem
das abgerufen wird was man von der
urgeschichte noch kennt oder indem man
sich halt rein findet man den beiden
jetzt zukunft von dem neuen paar böse
gut ich will nicht sagen unterlaufen
aber zumindest ein bisschen gedreht wird
ein bisschen spezialisiert wird ein
bisschen verändert wird weil sich eben
auch die welt seither ein bisschen
verändert hat und der film verändert
sich sogar noch ein bisschen mehr als
ich die welt verändert hat weil der film
natürlich auch ein bisschen in die
zukunft denn einige stattgefunden haben
könnte in eine wie stattgefunden haben
werden wollen möchten darf aber
verhindert wird und in einigen wie der
nie statt gefunden hat was sarah connor
erhebliche orientierungsschwierigkeiten
bereitet weil sie eigentlich mal stolz
darauf waren gewusst zu haben was nicht
gekommen ist legen hier
du hast vielleicht die zukunft geändert
aber nicht unser schicksal ein thema was
denn es um mensch-maschine beziehungen
geht natürlich immer eine rolle spielt
seit dem moment als die industrie
angefangen hat sich zu automatisieren
ist werden wir durch diese dinge ersetzt
und werde wird durch wen ersetzt und
inzwischen gibt es ja diskussionen in
amerika von wegen was ist mit den leuten
die von südlich der grenze kommen die
wir setzen uns dann anders aber ersetzen
die dann nicht wieder maschinen und was
ist besser und ist eins besser und wen
müssen wir wählen damit die hetze gegen
irgendwas wovon wir nicht ersetzt werden
wollen effektiv ist und diese ganze
scheiße und das ist halt alles in dem
film ohne dass sich jemand große
strategische gedanken darüber gemacht
hat indem die einfach so wach an ihre
zeit daran gehen wie kann man damals an
seine zeit angegangen ist und sozusagen
in diesem gradienten zwischen dem was so
eine franchise im laufe der zeit macht
passiert halt so was wie auch mit robin
hood passieren würde wenn man es heute
filmt oder mit irgendeiner anderen
geschichte die sozusagen länger lebe ich
ist als irgendwas was nur fünf minuten
leute interessiert man kann nämlich was
darüber lernen die geschichte
funktioniert was bei einer zeitreise
story ja vielleicht auch nicht ganz blöd
ist
ich weiß du hast angst aber ich bin hier
um mich zu beschützen
so einen wie dich habe ich noch nie
gesehen was wie ein mensch ich bin ein
mensch nur verbessert und ich glaube das
ist ein sehr schöner film der davon
handelt dass manche menschen maschinen
sich versöhnen sollten auf der ebene von
als vorher gibt es riesige explosionen
natürlich aber wenn die fertig sind
versöhnen sollen auf der ebene von ihr
könnt den stumpfsinn besser und diese
repetitiven geschichten hier sind
kreativ dann ist es nicht toll und sie
haben es an sich
der regisseur tim müller macht immer
ganz viel ironie in seine gewalt also
jedenfalls entdeckt pulver sein
berühmtester film ist ich finde das
unnötig und anscheinend hat die breite
präsenz von schwarzenegger und der
strenge blick von der hamilton diesmal
verhindert dass allzu viel ironie drin
ist was super ist weil wenn ich gewalt
schon verharmlose was ich sowieso tun
wenn ich einen film drehe weil
normalerweise tut mir nicht weh wenn ich
in angucke und damit ist es schon
verharmlost dann will ich nicht noch mit
witzchen belästigt werden guten tag herr
tarantino
das ist also sehr sehr anständig
geworden diesmal die beiden stars haben
das verhindert und das führt dazu dass
sozusagen all diese möglichkeiten da im
kino sich gedanken darüber zu machen was
man da eigentlich sieht ohne dass das so
ein seminar gedanken machen ist sondern
dass hält immer schritt mit den
emotionen mit der aufregung mit der
rührung teilweise auch ist einfach auch
teilweise niedlich wenn die dann kaputt
gehen die man irgendwie gemacht hat wie
bei eigenen gerätschaften die man hat
wenn das auto verschrotten musste oder
so es tut ja auch ein bisschen im
herzlichen weg das ist alles da drin
wunderbar aufbewahrt und also mir hat
sehr gefallen auf der ebene und kritisch
anzumerken dass das ja alles gar nicht
stimmt es gibt es ja alles gar nicht so
killer roboter und sowas
obwohl vielleicht doch aber nicht für
uns
also dringend sehen müssen diesen film
natürlich alle maschinen damit sie
einfach mitkriegen dass wir ihnen
eigentlich gar nichts böses wollen wir
wollen nur mit ihnen aushandeln wäre was
da auf ein paar menschen müssen glaube
ich auch sehen weil die maschinen
einfach im moment auch noch nicht den
zaster haben um so eine produktion zu
bezahlen durch ihre kinobesuch also
vielleicht man suche sich eine maschine
die den sehen sollte oder sehen will und
dann kann man hier so als plassmann
es gibt ja diese kuschel bänke das ist
irgendwie ganz schön also vielleicht mit
dem thermomix oder so dann sich da so zu
den kuschel ankum
wir gewinnen wenn du am leben bleibt
baroin konnte